Çeviri: Ahmet Erdogan Asliyuce
Gözden geçirme: Batuhan Çevik
Hepinize merhabalar!
Hayatı eksiksiz bir şekilde deneyimliyorum
Bugün hayat hikayemi
sizlerle paylaşmak için buradayım.
İsmim Buket Ela, sosyoloğum.
Boğaziçi Üniversitesi Dilbilim bölümünde,
Sağır toplumu ve işaret dili üzerine
araştırmalar yapan bir araştırmacıyım.
Aynı zamanda konuşan işiten camiası ile
sağır ve işitme engelli camiasını kapsayan
projeler yürütüyorum
Profesyonel ve gönüllü
anlamda çalışıyorum.
Bütün bunlar bir yana,
gönüllü olarak yaptığım
işaret dili eğitmenliği, öğretmenliği
benim için çok sevdiğim bir meslek.
Size hayat hikayemi
paylaşacağımdan bahsettim ama
şu anda söylediklerimin hepsi
hayat hikayemin gelişme bölümü.
Biraz size giriş hikayesinden
bahsetmek istiyorum.
İki buçuk yaşında yüksek ateşten dolayı
havale geçirdim
ve iki kulaktan ileri derecede
işitme kaybım var.
Evet sizi duymuyorum, sahneye girdiğimde
belki alkışladınız bunu duymadım.
Konuştuğunuz zaman sizi duymuyorum ama
dudak okuyarak sesinizi duyabiliyorum.
Tabii şu an bunu dudak okuduğumu söylüyor
olmam çok rahat, çok kolaymış gibi ama
bu büyük bir tecrübe ve
tesadüfen fark ettiğim bir süreçti.
Belki kendinizden hatırlarsınız,
belki çevrenizde okuma yazmayı yeni sökmüş
çocuklara falan denk gelmişsinizdir.
Onlarda böyle çılgınca bir heyecan var,
Ah işte bunu anladım, bunu okuyorum gibi
ve ben bu heyecanı biraz beşinci sınıfta
yaşadığımı hatırlıyorum.
Hayal meyal,
aslında çok da küçük bir yaş değil.
Fakat, öğretmenimiz
"defterlerinizi çıkarın, ben size
söyleyeceğim, siz yazacaksınız" derdi.
Okuma ve yazmamızı geliştirmek için
yaptığı bir şey,
Tabii diğer arkadaşlarım gibi
-İşiten, konuşan diğer arkadaşlarım gibi-
heyecanlanıyorum.
Benim de yazmam lazım;
Çünkü kitaptan baktığımda yazıyorum,
düşündüklerimi yazıyorum...
Evet, söktüm ben bunu falan diyorum ama
şimdi öğretmenimiz sınıf içerisinde
dolaşırken
o anlattıklarını, söylediklerini
bir türlü geçiremiyorum.
Kulağımda işitme cihazı var,
bu işitme cihazıyla mekanik
sesleri alıyorum ama...
Şimdi bir ses geliyor
ama ne söylüyor?
Tabii o dönemde hasta olduğumu düşünerek.
Evet ben duymuyorum, anlamıyorum,
yapamıyorum, beceriksizim...
Halbuki o an ne dudak okuduğumun
bilincindeyim,
ne işitme engelliliğin sessizlik
olduğunun farkındayım.
Daha doğrusu şöyle söylemek
istiyorum size:
Son zamanlarda işitme engelliliği daha iyi
anlayabilmek için, empati için
kulaklarınızı kapattığınız zaman
yaşadığınız sessizlik...
Evet işitme engelliler böyle
hissediyorlarmış gibi
yaşadığı durum buymuş gibi
bir kıyaslama var.
Ama şimdi düşünüyorum,
eğer bir işitme engellinin
nasıl hissettiğine dair
bir empati kurmak istiyorsanız
konuştuğunuz dili unutmanız lazım.
Düşünme tarzınızı, bakış açınızı
unutmanız gerekiyor.
Bunu tıpkı yabancı bir dil öğrendiğiniz
zaman o dilin kültüründeki
farklı deyimler, farklı atasözleri, onları
öğrendiğiniz durum gibi düşünebilirsiniz.
Yoksa kulaklarınızı kapattınız,
sessizlik.
Oh ne ala, sessiz...
Ama işitme engellilik
böyle bir şey değil.
Ben bu eğitim hayatım süresince,
bu süreç içinde, gidip geliyorum.
Hani kimim, neyim?
Çevremde benim gibi,
böyle bir çıkmaz içinde kimse yok.
Tabi dudak okuduğumu rahat
fark etmediğimi söylemiştim,
tesadüfen fark ettim.
Şöyle ki liseden mezun oldum,
bir şekilde mezun oldum.
Ve dershane hayatımda
yaşadığım farklılık ortamları,
Artık beni çok idare eden insanlar yok,
çok daha farklı insanlar var.
Dedim ki bir arkadaşıma:
“Yarın sınav var mı?”
Bana dedi ki,
"Buket" dedi
“Neden benimle
salak salak konuşuyorsun?”
Şimdi kendimce düşünüyorum;
acaba yanlış bir şey mi söyledim,
yanlış bir şekilde mi ifade ettim,
acaba bana bir şey sordu, ben konuyu
başka bir yere mi çekiyorum gibi...
Tabii bunları
hep ışık hızıyla düşünüyorum.
Tabii ben bunları düşünürken
yüzüm düştüğü için bana diyor ki:
“Buket, ben seni kırmak istemedim
ama anlamak için soruyorum."
"Benimle neden böyle konuşuyorsun?”
“Nasıl konuşuyorum ki?” dedim.
Hani bunları söylüyor ama
yakalamakta zorlanıyorum.
"Yarın ders var mı?"
"Yarın sınav var mı?"
Benim o an taklidimi
yaptığındaki halimi...
Kaldım. Bir boşluğun içine düşmüş gibi
hissettim.
Hani dedim acaba neden o kişiye bu şekilde
konuşuyorum, konuşmayı mı bilmiyorum?
Meğerse o kişide dudak tembelliği
olduğu için,
onu anlayamadığım için,
benimle daha iyi anlaşabilsin diye
dudaklarımı hareket ettiriyorum ki
o da ettirsin.
Sonra fark ettim ki karşımızdaki insanın
bize nasıl davranmasını,
bizim karşımızdakinin bize
nasıl davranmasını istiyorsak
o şekilde davranıyormuşuz.
Bunu fark ettim ama,
bakın dikkatinizi çekerim;
liseden mezun olmuşum,
bir ergenlik ve gençlik sürecindeyim.
Tabii şimdi bu kendimi bildim bileli
içinde yaşadığım boşluk hissi.
Bir etiket vuruyorum buna evet.
Çok içimde, derinlerde...
Hani taşımasam da, düşünmesem de;
peşimden gelen bir boşluk bu.
Ama bir şeyler yanlış,
bir eksiklik var.
Acaba nedir falan diye bir sorguluyorum.
Sonra fark ettim ki ifade edememe,
o iletişim konusunda bocalıyorum.
Sonra tabii bir şekilde bunu kabul ederken
yine aynı arkadaşımla,
-çok fevri biridir kendisi-
yine kalabalık bir ortamdayız.
Hocalar, öğretmenler var.
Mola verdiğimiz bir alanda.
Ben de hemen bir çay semaverinin olduğu
yerin yanında duruyorum.
Hocamız bana bir şey söylüyor,
ben de diyorum ki:
“Aa, evet çay çok güzel!”
Bundan sonra yine o arkadaşım
yanıma gelip bana diyor ki, Buket diyor...
“Neden hocaya o kadar çok çıkıştın?”
Hayda...
Şimdi dudak da hareket ettirmedim,
hani öğrenmiştim onu.
Acaba bu sefer nerede
yanlış yaptım falan...
Sonra şunu fark ettim:
Hoca bana bir şey söylediğinde
o zamanı hesap edemiyorum.
Hani benim duymadığım kaygısından dolayı,
hemen bir cevap verme mealindeyim.
Ama halbuki ne söylediğini
tam anlamış değilim.
Meğerse bana demiş ki:
“Buket bana bir çay verir misin?”
Ben de ona diyorum ki:
“Çay çok güzel”.
Tabii böyle ortamlarda, şu an
söylediğim gibi rahat gibi kalıyor
ama bu ufak bir örnekti.
Daha farklı ortamlarda,
ortamdan çok ötekileştirildiğim oldu.
Ve tabi bunu yaşarken arkadaşım bana
bu örneği verdiğinde,
ortaokuldan bir arkadaşım
kulak misafiri olup dedi ki:
“Buket, ortaokulda da
çok bağırarak konuşuyordu."
Hayda...
Yani o zamana kadar gelmişim, bu şeyleri
o zaman fark ediyor oluyor olmam...
Sanki üçüncü bir kişiden bahsediyorlar.
İşte Buket diye biri var da,
şöyle yapıyor falan
Meğerse gerçekten
çok bağırarak konuşuyormuşum.
Neden?
Kendi sesimi duymadığım için,
sesimi karşı tarafa duyurmaktan ziyade
kendime duyurmak için bağırıyorum
ya da insanlar beni anlamıyor diye,
daha iyi anlasınlar diye bağırıyorum.
Fark etmişsinizdir,
toplumda insanlar birbirleriyle
daha çok bağırarak konuşurlar.
Hani dinlemeleri için
Ama o ses yüksekliği;
dinlemek, anlamak olmuyor.
Tabii ben kendimi geliştirdim ama
o durumdan bana bahsedince
bir korku içine düştüm.
Çünkü neden?
Öğretmen bana bir şey söyledi,
ben bir şey cevap verdim.
Şimdi desem ki size
benim parmağımda yüzük var.
Görme yetisi olan biri parmağıma baktığı
zaman yüzüğü görüyorsa var,
görme yetisi olmayan biri dokunduğu
zaman evet yüzük var.
Ama o sesin ispatını ben
nasıl yapıyor olacağım?
On iki yıllık bir eğitim hayatım var,
bu hayatımda gerçekten bana ne söylendi,
ben bunu nasıl algıladım,
nasıl cevap verdim?
Hangileri doğruydu?
Tabii biraz da bu gençliğin verdiği bir
stres, gerilim vesaire
O dönem tabi ki üniversiteyi kazanamadım.
Bir daha girdim üniversite sınavına,
yine kazanamadım.
Sonra bir daha girdim,
Dedim bu işte bir eksiklik,
bir sıkıntı, bir şey var yani.
Bu merakım tabi burada
biraz daha devreye girdi.
Hayır dedim benim bu sınava
biraz daha bilinçli girmem lazım,
bir şeyleri başarmam gerekiyor.
Ve daha bilinçli bir şekilde
ve alternatif sunarak girdim.
Dedim ki:
beden eğitimi öğretmenliğini deneyeyim,
resim öğretmenliğini deneyeyim.
Eski dönemler bilir daha çok,
üniversite sınavlarında kazanamayınca
daha çok özel yeteneklere yöneliyorlar.
Sonra aynı yıl resim öğretmenliği
Malatya ve
İstanbul'da Mimar Sinan Üniversitesi
sosyolojiyi kazandım.
Öğretmenlik tabi garanti bir meslek.
İşte kız çocuğuyum, duymuyorum,
birinin beni koruması gerekiyor falan.
Tabii ailem sevgi, sonsuz sevgi
o çok ayrı bir şey.
Ama bugün bu bütün konuşmam içinde
fark etmenizi istediğim şey
sevgiden daha önemli, daha anlamlı
görebileceğiniz şey: anlamak, anlaşılmak.
Tabii destek oldular bana ama
ben hayır dedim
sosyoloji okuyacağım dedim,
İstanbul'a geldim
ve üniversiteyi bitirmem gereken yaşta
üniversiteye başladım.
Fakat çevremdeki insanlarla
ilişki kuramıyorum.
Neden? Çünkü daha önce
hep beni birileri idare ediyordu.
Birileri bir şekilde beni koruyormuş.
Burada her şey tabii yüzünüze
biraz daha çarpıyor.
O fevri arkadaşım çok ayrı bir durum.
Ama bu öz eleştiriye
ve eleştiriye sahip olarak
üniversiteye başlamış olmam
benim için çok büyük bir adım olmuş oldu.
Ve bana dediler ki:
“Buket sen hem duymuyorsun
hem çok akıcı konuşuyorsun.”
Evet, mucizevi bir şey gibi. Ama hani
bahsetmiştim ya içimde bir eksiklik var.
İstanbul’a geldiğimde ne onlardan
ne bunlardanım.
Kimim ben?
Şimdi akıcı konuşuyor olduğum için
bir işiten sağır bir birey değilim
ama duymadığım için de konuşan-işiten
bir birey değilim.
E kimim?
Zaten geçmişte, çocukluğum, gençliğim
süresince böyle bir bocalama içindeyken
şimdi tekrar böyle bir şeyle
yüz yüze geldim.
Ama şuna çok sevinmiştim:
hatta böyle dışardan beni biri gördüğü
zaman ayıplayacağını düşünüyordum.
İstanbul’da başka işitme engelliler var.
Onları görünce sarılıyordum,
ah benim gibi insanlar var,
ben yalnız değilmişim diye.
Hani yurt dışında çok uzak yerlerde, başka
bir Türk gördüğünüz zaman
sevinirsiniz ya ona
benzer bir şey galiba.
Tabii sonrasında işaret dilini öğrendim,
keşfetmeye başladım.
Bir dil konuşuyorum evet,
dil konuşuyorum ama
"İşaret dili"
Yanlış anlaşılmamak,
yanlış anlamamak.
O dilin muhteşem bir hazzı.
Bunu nasıl ifade edebilirim bilemiyorum
Mucizevi bir şekilde konuşuyor
olabilirim ama,
bunu size anlatabilmem çok çok zor.
Ve bu dili öğrenmemle birlikte müthiş
aktif bir hayatım başladı.
Malatya’dayken, ev-okul, dershane-okul-ev
vs. bu şekilde geçen bir çemberden
bir anda sosyal hayatımda daha aktifim,
iş hayatında çalışabiliyorum,
insanlarla anlaşabiliyorum.
Beni telefonla aramadan
SMS ile bizzat iletişime geçip
buluşabilen arkadaşlar edindim.
Çünkü Malatya’dayken, sadece
sağırlar işitme cihazı kullanıyordu.
Ben de acaba yaşlı mıyım,
hasta mıyım falan diye...
Halbuki işitme engelliliğin
bir hastalık olmadığını fark ettim.
Çünkü dille beraber
bir kültüre kavuştum,
iletişimle beraber yaşamın kendisini
bizzat deneyimlemeye başladım.
Tabi artık on sekiz saattir ayaktayım,
sürekli bir şeylere koşuşturuyorum.
Sivil toplum örgütlerinde çalıştım,
bu alanda bir sürü projeler
gerçekleştiriyorum.
Ailem de diyor ki,
Buket diyorlar:
“İstanbul’un havası sana yaramış.”
Şimdi onun dil olduğunu,
onlara anlatmam o kadar çok zor ki.
Bir dudak okuduğumu bile on yedi,
on sekiz yaşında keşfetmiş biriyim.
Hani zannediyorlar ki bir engel
teşhis edildiğinde, tanı konulduğunda
beraberinde nasıl bir tedavi süreci
olduğunu bize veriyorlar gibi.
Halbuki böyle bir şey yok.
Ne yapmam gerektiğini hep düşe kalka,
düşe kalka, düşe kalka öğrendim.
Tabii dedim evet, ben hasta değilim
ama hani bir farklılık var.
Şu anda hepiniz bireysel olarak
birbirinizden çok farklısınız.
Elinizde olmayan fiziki
özellikleriniz var.
Bedeniniz, teninizin rengi,
boyunuz, kemik yapınız gibi.
Evet benim de bir işitme kaybım var,
duymuyorum.
Bu da benim elimde olmayan
bir fiziki özelliğim
ve hayatımı buna göre
şekillendiriyorum.
Bu bir yaşam biçimi.
Bunu, bu kimliği ediniyor olmak,
sağır kimliğini edinmiş olmak;
bir birey olarak, bir kadın olarak,
bir insan olarak
artık ayaklarımı sağlam bir şekilde
yere basıyor olmak muhteşem bir şey.
Neden?
Çünkü sürekli hastasın, iyileşeceksin,
bir beklentiye giriyorsunuz...
Şimdi, Malatya’daki hayatımda bir sene
içinde dört beş kere acile gidiyordum.
Sürekli bir ağrım, hastalık vs.
Ama İstanbul’a gelince hiçbir şekilde,
hastalıklarım minimum.
Kendini ifade ediyor olabilmek fiziki
olarak o kadar çok iyileştiriyor ki.
Ama işaret dili beni çok çok iyileştirdi.
Ve derler ya dil,
insanı kafesinden çıkarıyor diye.
Galiba ben kafesten çıktım,
öyle bir uçuyorum, öyle bir uçuyorum ki
o uçuşun sesini duyabiliyorum, uçuşumun.
Bu süreçle birlikte tabii,
bunun farkındalığını sağlamış oldum.
Belli bir yaş geçmiş olsa da.
Fakat toplumda da bir durum var,
yani iletişim karşılıklı.
Evet sizi duymuyorum evet, ama siz de
kendi sesinizi bana duyuramıyorsunuz.
Fakat çoğunluk siz olduğunuz için,
azınlık biz olduğumuz için
engelli etiketi bizde kalıyor.
Fakat,
aslında engelleniyoruz.
Yoksa ben hiçbir zaman ah duyamıyorum,
çok üzülüyorum, ağlıyorum...
Duymadığım için üzülüp ağladığım
zamanları sorguladığımda
aslında duymadığım için üzülmüyorum çünkü
zaten sizin nasıl duyduğunuzu bilmiyorum.
Kaybettiğim şey ses mi?
Kaybettiğim şey birlikte sizinle sinemaya
gidip alt yazıyla izleyemiyor olmak.
Evde herkes televizyon izlediği zaman,
sadece kuru gürültüyü çekiyor olmak.
Mekanik seslerle o sıkıntıyı çekiyor olup
ortama ayak uydurmak.
Ama bu bir alt yazıyla, bir işaret diliyle
o topluma dahil olduğunuz zaman,
sizinle beraber aynı zevki alıyor olmak,
işte o zaman engel durumu kalkıyor.
Toplumda tabi sınıf arkadaşları,
iş arkadaşları,
ortamda farklı bir engel grubu,
farklı gelişim gösteren bireyler yoksa
o kişi nasıl iletişime geçmesi
gerektiğiyle ilgili bir bocalıyor.
Ben de bu anlamda zaten seminerler,
iletişim seminerleri düzenliyorum.
Orada bir şey fark ediyorum, topluma
ben de dahil oluyorum ve giriyorum.
Mesela toplu taşıma aracında,
akbili basıp geçip arkaya oturuyorum.
Neden? Çünkü önde genelde
teyzeler falan oturur, amcalar oturur,
bir şeyler sorar, torunlarını anlatır...
İşte bende bir gelin var,
düşman başına...
Sonra tabii ben de iki dil biliyorum ama
karşımdaki insanı bilmiyorsam,
ortama hakim değilsem
daha çok işaret dilini tercih ediyorum.
Eğer karşımdaki insanla anlaşabileceğimi
düşünüyorsam, Türkçe de konuşuyorum.
Öyle durumlarda işte bana dedi ki teyze:
"Şuradan geçiyor mu?"
Ben de dudak okuduğumu söyledim,
ama bu her zaman beşte beş değil.
Bazı sesleri alıyorum ama,
her zaman o sesi alamıyorum.
Gerçekte ses var mı yok mu?
Mesela şimdi size desem ki:
benim sol kolum yok,
siz sadece baktığınız zaman,
görmediğiniz zaman ikna oluyorsunuz.
Ama sizi duymadığıma ikna etmem...
(Parmak şıklatıyor)
Bunu da mı?
(Alkış tutuyor)
Hiç mi?
Şimdi evet desem, hani duymuyordun?
E hayır desem?
Ömrümün çoğunu hep kendimi başkalarına
ispat etmek, onları ikna etmekle geçirdim.
Tabii teyzeye dönersek,
bana işte o beş kelimesinde
bir yerden geçiyor mu diye
soruyor ama
o ilk üç kelimeyi anlamıyorum.
Ben de kulağımı gösterdim.
Sonra bir daha sordu,
sesini biraz daha yükselterek.
Ben de işte cihazımı gösterdim,
işitme cihazını görürse.
Yok dedim.
Hiç mi duymuyorsun?
Aa dedim yine başlıyoruz.
Sonra şöyle bir yüzüme baktı
ama dedi sen çok güzel bir kadınsın.
Şimdi engelliyim, kadınım...
Güzel olmamam mı gerekiyor?
Hani?
Tabii bazen insanlar böyle karşılaştığım
zaman direkt şunu da soruyorlar:
Engelliyim, işitme engelliyim,
"annen baban da mı işitme engelli?"
Ya da arkadaşlarla tartışınca "sen işitme
engelli olduğun için mi tartıştınız?"
Hatta evli olduğumu duyup şaşıranlar...
"Senin eşin de mi şey?"
Hı hı, şey...
Değil, konuşan.
Konuşan, işitme engelli evli olamaz
gibi bir durum mu var?
Daha da ileriye gidip
çocuğunun işitme engelli olmasından
korkuyor musun diye soranlar da var.
Evet, benim bir korkum var,
ama o korkum bebeğin bir engel
durumuna sahip olmasından ziyade
o zihinler tarafından engelleniyor olması.
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkür ediyorum.
(Alkış)